it's time for the launching Chronicle a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought so you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which
snore watts company maker all launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the long
team Chronos cope mr. William Bradford
Huie editor of the american mercury and
mr. carl
hess press editor of newsweek magazine
our distinguished guest for this evening
is the honorable stiles bridges United
States Senator from New Hampshire the
opinions expressed are necessarily those
of the speaker so two bridges I'm sure
that our viewers will be glad to see you
back on the karna strophic and a knight
sir and as Republican leader in the
United States Senate
why we'll welcome your views on some of
the current developments now sir senator
taft has had an air rather important
meeting with general eisenhower I'm sure
that you were interested in that and I'd
like you to tell our viewers just what
you think was the result of that meeting
between general eisenhower and Senator
Taft I think it brought together the two
of the great factions of the Republican
Party and I think that there was a
general agreement as a result of the
conference I think that it means that
Taft will support wholeheartedly the
eyes now our candidacy and I think that
the difference is which they may have
had before as a result of their
conferences have been so resolved that
the area of difference is between the
two is slight and the tap can do it with
a clear conscience and all
what do you think this will mean any
change in the tenor of the campaign I
think if anything it will have a
tendency an attached to step up the
campaign we will test for instance speak
more specifically I think tap will
pinpoint the issues that he's
particularly concerned with and intends
to pull on a very vigorous type of
campaign of course as a Republican
leader in the Senate I know that you
yourself have been very interested in
uniting the party now do you foresee sir
that by November the 4th you think that
you will have a United Republican Party
I do yes I do very definitely you don't
think that any of the so-called extreme
right factions will hold back from
supporting general and I think that the
issues will be so clear clarified that
there that the right and conservative
wing of the Republican Party as perhaps
exemplified by the TAT faction of the
Taft leadership role will be such a
difference between me and the left-wing
tendencies of the Democratic campaign
that they'll have no difficulty in
making their choice the other extremely
interesting development now then of
course the smashing victory of Senator
McCarthy in Wisconsin now will you tell
our viewers how you interpret the
meaning of that surprise I think that
son of a Chavez victory in Wisconsin by
such a tremendous my margin indicates
that the people of Wisconsin certainly
endorse wholeheartedly the objectives
which he sought which is to rid the
government agencies of this country of
subversive elements will you surprise
her at the raziel I was surprised at the
magnitude the size of it I was not
surprised at the vector we pleasantly
surprised pleasantly surprised do you
feel in that McCarthy support for anyone
during the campaign
be valuable I do I think that it well
because I think people to most people in
the country McCarthy was they agree with
all of his methods all that he said they
agree that McCarthy is sort of a symbol
of action and people want action in
eliminating the bad influences the
subversives from the government of the
United are a specifically of course sir
you are interested in electing the
public as the United States Senate now
do you think that McCarthy can be useful
outside Wisconsin in the election of
Republicans to the Senate yes I think
you'd be an asset in any state the Union
well well we have a Republican County is
there any place where he isn't welcome I
think the only state that I've heard of
and particularly was a statement coming
out of Connecticut recently where one of
the candidates for the senator than that
state indicated that there did intend to
make use of Sarah McCarthy you regard
that as a tactical error on the part of
the Republicans in Connecticut and I do
yes would it be a similar tactical error
for Eisenhower to continue to ignore
well I think Eisenhower as our candidate
must recognize the McCarthy victory
there and its significance and this
magnitude is there any reason to believe
he will I rather think that he well yes
well senator now our order is a number
of the manager know that you yourself
have been making the number of trips out
into the country and that you are
supporting the ticket actively now what
are interesting observations do you have
for us from those trips that you've been
making well I come away with a definite
feeling and I'm just and wrote back now
from rather a lengthy trip that the
campaign the Republican campaign is
picking up gathering momentum and if it
the recent tendency to pick up to gather
momentum carries forward as I have every
reason to believe that it will I think
it's a good old man is there a
difference between the things that the
people you've spoken to are interested
in and the things Eisenhower has
well I mean I find that particularly
people are interested in certain
definite issues which is do you by
sector for instance they're very
interested in career and our action or
attitude in Korea they're very
interested in taxes they're very
interested in winning the delicate
agencies of the government from all the
communist influences well you know about
their being interested in in in Texas
sir do you think that's one of the major
issues yes I do
I believe that terror it is initial that
is felt by some Fattah you're right
million taxpayers now I wonder if that's
typical you of course are a Yankee in a
New England there is everybody in the
country's worried about money as you
people are a lot a or up in New England
we are interested in money we like to
see the American dollar worth a dollar
and we're getting worried I was over in
Canada the other day and purchased an
item for $8.00 I gave this shopkeeper
$8.00 and he said 32 more cents buddy
your dollar isn't worth as much as used
to be well that was a shock to me why
because I was brought up in the New
England state along the Canadian border
and all from the time of my childhood on
the Canadian dollar sold at a discount
of 10 to 15 cents in American dollar now
to find that the American dollar is
selling over this town not the Canadian
dollar it's a terrific shot to make well
senator now I believe you've been in the
Senate sent something like 1936 that's
right you're number one and the
Republican I am yes meaning you've been
there long with
any other Republican and you're still a
relatively young man I believe I hope so
now sir
ideally much of a chance now or a great
chance of a Republican Senate and a
Republican House I think if we have any
trend in this election which I believe
we have that we have an excellent chance
to capture both the Senate and House but
then it will be by a small margin what
we can capture will these campaigns in
the Senate and the house be pitched
differently from the national campaign
as far as well I mean the overall will
be the same but the individual
candidates in the respective states will
emphasize the particular and specific
issues coming back to yourself sir you
regard yourself as a conservative in the
United States Senate now well when I
came to the Senate from the governorship
of New Hampshire up there I was regarded
as sort of a ranked progressive and I
suppose most people do they regard me as
sort of a conservative when ideas
haven't changed does that mean that you
are opposed to the so-called social you
know and if there's anything that makes
me sick and tired is to have Democrats
and new dealers all around this country
telling if the Republicans get in
they'll turn back the pages of to the
dark ages that's pure undiluted buck and
as a matter of fact Republicans
generally approve the sound social game
and anything in your own record that
indicates that yes when I was governor
of New Hampshire my state the lone state
of New Hampshire was the first state in
the United States to qualify under the
federal Social Security Act we put
through the first of the second
unemployment insurance law in the
country we put through mothers aid which
was an initial step in the country and
we set up the first cancer research
commission and clinics in the country
how would the Republican achievement of
these social gains so-called social
gains legislations differ from the
Democratic well I think that there
that's a good point I think the the
Republicans would like to see and not
everything centered in the federal
government we'd like to see that a
corporate adventure with as much
emphasis put in the states and local
control and local operations as possible
the federal government only coming in to
coordinate or playing a smaller part as
possible as Republican leader leader the
Republicans in the Senate you don't know
of any tendency or any desire on the
part of the Republicans to repeal any of
the major donor legislation or to change
any other all I think there may be some
changes that would be sound in the right
direction but I don't know of any to
repeal any of the sound social
legislation it would be towards state
control individual state control a
senator as a final question sir since
you are particularly interested in the
Senate races I'm sure that our viewers
would like to you to tell us the states
in which you think the Republicans have
the best chance to gain seats in the
Senate this year I think we have an
excellent chance to gain two seats in
Connecticut seat in in Maryland a seat
in Michigan estate in Wyoming a scene in
New Mexico seed in West Virginia and a
seat in Kentucky and there may be some
others and Arizona we have a good
fighting chance in Arizona and it's your
belief that there is an excellent chance
then toward I can see that where we
could capture the Senate by a 2 3 or 4
volt margin well sir I'm certain that
our viewers have very much appreciated
these views from you tonight and thank
you for being with us the editorial
board for this edition of the launching
Chronicle was mr. William Bradford Huie
and mr. Carl hips our distinguished
guests was the honorable stiles bridges
United States Senator from New Hampshire
long gene watches appeal to particular
people men and women of distinction who
looked for faultless appearance and
performance in a watch as well as in
other things that they buy now that
solid worth also appeal to you for
excellence and for elegance long jane is
the only watch in history to win 10
world's fair grand prizes twenty eight
gold medal awards for accuracy launching
watches have won countless honors from
the world's great government
observatories in an on gene watch
discriminating men and women find
faultless finish and performance and
remember if you pay seventy 150 or more
for a watch you're paying the price of a
lone gene and you should insist on
getting a long gene for throughout the
world no other name on a watch means so
much as launching the world's most
honored watch premier product of the
long gene with nor wats company same
eighteen sixty six maker of watches of
the highest character
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at this
same time for the launching Chronos code
a television journal of the important
issues of the our broadcast on behalf of
launching the world's most honored watch
and wit nor distinguished companion to
the world on a long gene this is frank
night reminding you that long chain and
with nor watches are sold and serviced
from coast to coast by more than four
thousand leading jewelers who proudly
display this emblem agency for launching
with nor watches
the world most honored murdered is long
gone gene watches have won ten world's
fair grand prizes twenty eight gold
medals and more honors for accuracy than
any other timepiece Bonjean the world's
most honored watch is made in guaranteed
by the lone gene with no watch company
it's time for the launching promise of a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour draw so you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which nor
what company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching Chronos cope our mr. William
Bradford Huie editor of the american
mercury and mr. edgar baker managing
editor of Time Life international our
distinguished guest for this evening is
the honorable stiles bridges United
States Senator from New Hampshire the
opinions expressed are necessarily those
of the speakers
senator bridges you of course have had a
long and distinguished career in the
Senate and tonight our chrono scope
audience is tremendously interested in
all the furor over the president's
seizure of the steel mills I'm sure that
we'd like your opinions tonight sir now
is this an unprecedented action on the
part of the president sir well Miss
Chile I've been in the Senate some 16
years I would say that there has been a
greater revulsion from the country on
this in the last few days the many
issues since I've been in the Senate
except the court packing scheme of
President Roosevelt and the removal of
General Douglas MacArthur by President
Truman I think those two both of those
issues created a greater comeback from
the country but certainly next to those
two issues the seizure of the steel
mills and this unprecedented action
comes next you think that the public is
genuinely aroused do you sir I think
they are becoming aroused as they view
the consequences and the full meaning of
massager and and you feel sir as a as a
veteran of the Senate do you feel that a
grave constitutional issue is involved
that there is justification for the
people's being aroused I do I'll tell
you why mr. cheeley because always
before we've had private property seized
by the President of the United States
before in various cases but always
before that's been based upon some
statutory authority some basis of law
this is the first time and the president
has ever taken such a step when we
haven't had on the statute books a
Pacific law which he attributed his
action to your tell sir excuse me you're
telling our audience that that in your
opinion there is no statute on the books
now that would justify the president's
act I am is well senator what were the
practical alternatives or what were
there alternatives was there another
course the president could have followed
yes as a preventative damaging STIs he
certainly could have invoked the
provisions of the taft-hartley Act but
as you know mr. Baker he has so used the
taft-hartley act as a whipping boy for a
period of years that I suppose he
hesitated to use it in this instance but
he could invoke the taft-hartley Act
which would have brought on a furthest
day of 80 days and then he could have
taken a step by asking the Attorney
General of the United States to bring an
injunction in the courts against a
strike and then he cost the taft-hartley
Act and the we have other legislation
which would provide for him coming to
Congress for a recourse action well
senator now that the president has an
effect passed the ball back to Congress
by sending his message which some people
have interpreted as a confession of
error and in that it concedes that the
final decision does rest with the
Congress what what action would you
expect to be forthcoming from Capitol
Hill I think that dear first it should
be examined very carefully by the
Judiciary Committee of the Senate which
is the legal committee of the Senate and
this certainly is a legal constitutional
question and the action that's occurred
in the Senate which we've just seen in
the papers tonight about the Labor
Committee of the Senate going ahead and
holding hearings as dealing with
something which is a side issue the
issues involved in the strike are a side
issue the fundamental basic issue is the
President of the United States
assuming dictatorial powers in my
judgment and seizing a great industrial
you think sir that the constitutional
issue is overriding and must be decided
first at least before we decide who's
right and who's wrong in the labor
consequence of course what may happen
they may reach a decision on these
incidental issues which are the the
wages of the hours the union-shop for
the closed shop and so on
in the strike but Jerry the great issue
would would but still Rene the great
issue is still remaining they now mr.
Gillie mr. Baker if the President of the
United States can seize the steel mills
he can also buy the same ferry seized
cattle on the farms and the ranches he
can seize the poultry and the poultry
houses of the farms he can seize private
property anywhere because if you
remember when he took this stand and
issued this order he said I am taking
the stand by virtue of my authority
vested in me by the Constitution and the
laws of the United States and as
president of the United States and
commander of the Armed Services
he didn't list any specific law or any
definite law it was a very general broad
statement which he made which is a over
writing issue so you're saying sir that
this is not an ordinary capital versus
labor or management versus labor
controversy
it is very definitely more than that
when for instance the presidencies the
store of the coal mines during the war
he seized them under a definite statue
which was the Smith Conley act when he
sees the railroads he seized them under
the railroad Act of 1916 and so on when
he sees the Montgomery Ward plant he
sees it based upon the conscription act
so-called now we have none of those on
the statute books we have no long
statute so he's assuming some inherent
powers as commander in chief of the Army
Navy and to be consistent mr. Baker and
mr. Gillie what he should have done
instead of putting the Secretary of
Commerce in charge of the steel mills if
he assumed them as commander-in-chief
the Army Navy should put Secretary of
Defense in well sir but in this case
senator even in the very very few days
which elapsed between the time of the
decision of the Union to strike and the
president's action we lost a half
million tons of steel
now the president was faced with a very
practical very practical situation a
practical threat to the national defense
effort and and he cited his inherent
powers which I believe the courts have
been a number of occasions in the past
in different situations held that there
are inherent powers of the presidency
now what what is your feeling are there
no powers the president can use in a
situation of this nature where the
national defense may be endangered
charlie he could vote we have the
taft-hartley act as I said 80 days
waiting period he could have eyes for
the Attorney General to bring
injunctions in the courts and then it
pacifically says that he shall make a
report to Congress and for action by the
Congress and asked for definite
authority there were plenty of things
for him to do well sir now this is a
political year and so what are the
political implications here specifically
as a practical politician do you think
that this was smart politics for the
president well I I don't know I think
somewhat question that the president was
going to run again if he'd done it but
he's apparently not a candidate may I
point out also he was handicapped for
the fact that he's conducted this
fiction of a non war in Korea he says
this is a police action I think we're in
a war in Korea that the president has
avoided that issue and so he couldn't
resort to the fact that we're in a in a
Great War he's had to assume some pause
which somewhat unknown well now sir do
you think this this business is an
overriding issue I mean do you think
that the American public should be
gravely concerned in short is this a
step along the road toward a possible
dictatorship is it that serious yes I I
don't believe that till we're on the
road to dictatorship here yet but I say
that we we could be starting on the road
no for instance in all of these
socialistic countries where we are
afraid of socialism and so on there's no
socialist country that has seized by
of the ruling power mills for instance
when they go to nationalize the steel
mills in Great Britain they proceed in
an oddly matter manner according to the
law of the land
you're saying that not even in the
socialistic countries has there been so
aggressive inaction on the part of the
doctor garyun to the dictatorship powers
well that either the Communists will
assess somebody's run where you see
examples of this would you say that this
is a step toward possible
nationalization of the steel industry
and others could be yes it I hope not
but it could be but the final power to
prevent that rests with the Congress
yes it should rest mr. Baker with the
courts and if we had independent free
courts as I hope we have in some
instances certainly it might be in the
courts but in in any case the final
resort would be the balancing according
to our Constitution of the legislative
against the executive senator as we
understand it it is in a fight between
the Congress and the president and we
very much thank you for being with us
tonight sir the editorial board for this
edition of the launching Crona scope was
mr. William Bradford Huie
and mr. Edgar Baker our distinguished
guests was the honorable styles bridges
United States Senator from New Hampshire
one of the virtues of our free
enterprise system is the benefits to the
public in better quality and lower
prices which sprang from free and open
competition certainly the stimulus of
competition has resulted in ever finer
and finer lawn Jean watches and it was
in free and open competition that laun
Jean became in fact the world's most
honored watch honored for excellence and
elegance by ten world's fair grand
prizes twenty eight gold medal awards
honored for accuracy by innumerable
prizes and bulletins from the great
government observatories honored for
honesty in sports aviation exploration
science for superlative quality and true
investment value launching watches have
become first choice of discriminating
men and women in every country of the
free world so if you wish to purchase a
very fine watch either for yourself or
as a gift for a coming graduation for an
anniversary for any important occasion
look for the true quality and the watch
you buy and your choice will be Longy
the world's most honored watch premiere
product of the laun jean wit nor watch
company since eighteen sixty six maker
of watches of the highest character
this is David Ross speaking for your
host Frank Knight inviting you to join
us every monday wednesday and friday
evening at the same time for the long
gene Khurana scope a television journal
of important issues of the hour
broadcast on behalf of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene sold and serviced from
coast to coast by more than four
thousand leading jewelers who proudly
display the emblem agency for long Jean
wit nor watches
it's time for the launching Chronister
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought so you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday
a presentation of the laun gene which
snore what's company maker of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the long
gene Khurana scope mr. William Bradford
Huie editor of the american mercury and
mr. Henry Hazlitt editor of the freeman
and contributing editor of newsweek
magazine our distinguished guests for
this evening is the honorable Wallace F
Bennett United States Senator from Utah
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speakers the senator Bennet
you've made some vigorous speeches
lately about the president's seizure of
the steel industry
I wonder one to ask you what you think
the principal effects of that seizure
are now likely to be I think it has some
long-range implications and some that
are affecting us already I think the
principal long-range implication will be
felt in the continuing study of the
American people of the powers of the
President we're concerned again about
whether there are any limitations on the
powers of the president what do you
think will be done about that well the
Supreme Court may do it by its decision
and I think if the Supreme Court should
not do it we may expect before too long
to see a proposed amendment to the
Constitution which might spell out in
the Constitution the interpretation
given by Judge pine you're saying you're
telling our audience senator that in the
event the Supreme Court does not sustain
judge pine that you think that they that
Congress will then attempt to make judge
Pines
vision to write it into the Constitution
is that correct sir well I think that
will happen whether it'll happen at this
session of Congress which has a short
life ahead of it or whether that might
be postponed until 1958 as a member of
Congress and you think that that
Congress must soon in effect
specifically define the inherent powers
of the President Congress has the power
to amend the Constitution and the only
power to initiate that well that isn't
true the states have a concurrent power
but I think Congress will exercise that
power well you think they have the
intention you think that's the sentiment
of Congress at the present time that if
the supreme court fails to sustain judge
PI's decision that immediately Congress
will do something of this sort I think
if the matter we're up for a vote
tomorrow both houses would act that way
overwhelming well we'll have any effect
on labor legislation I think that may
need effect yeah I'm not sure how
immediate the effect will be because of
course the president has the
taft-hartley law and he hasn't used it
in this particular case and there are
many of us in Congress who feel that we
shouldn't have any new labor legislation
while this situation exists until after
the president has used taft-hartley but
for the long run I would expect some new
labor legislation to grow out of this
experience well along what lines would
it be a limitation of the right to
strike is that one of the lines it might
take well this sees your experience has
shown that there is a limitation of the
right to strike even the Union agrees
that it will not strike against the
government and judge Goldsboro in 1948
indicated that the courts take the
position that labor may not strike
against the ultimate interest of the
nation even though the government isn't
involved and there'll be any effort to
restrain industry-wide unions or try to
prevent the growth of these enormous
industry-wide unions I think that's a
possibility I was interested to discover
that when the Sherman law was passed in
1890 unions were included
as well as individuals and corporations
specifically included yes and they have
since escaped by oh by implication and
by direct amending legislation well
weren't they did immunized so to speak
under the Clayton law private and under
the norris-laguardia act and others that
may be restored now senator you say that
there is deep concern in the Senate over
this constitutional issue do you believe
that the American public is also deeply
concerned well I wish they were more
deeply concerned and I have the feeling
that this may have introduced a new
issue in the forthcoming campaign and I
hope the Republicans will do what they
can to create a more widespread concern
you say that you wish they were more
deeply concerned actually you have found
the public from your mail and otherwise
to be rather apathetic if you not well
my impression is the public are more
concerned about the immediate effects of
the strike and the seizure and the
implications of the price control
problem and they're not aware of the
fundamental constitutional problem as a
practical politician sir why do you
think that the American public is not
greatly concerned over this
constitutional issue which you regard is
so important well in the first place
many Americans feel that all
constitutional problems were settled 150
years ago on that we passed the point
where our fundamental problems have to
be consult again well this indifference
doesn't seem to be reflected in the
press do you think that there is a gap
between the protests and the press at
present and the feeling of the people
well the fact that the press so
overwhelmingly came out in opposition to
the president stand gives me hope that
in the months ahead its attitude will
actually be reflected in the public
opinion I'd like to ask what the effect
of this action will be on the control
powers on the extension of the control
powers and the kind of control powers
that you think you people in Congress
are going to let the president have
those are
effects are already evident so far as
the Senate is concerned the Senate
banking and currency committee has
completed its work on the law to extend
the President's powers and it was
practically finished with its work when
the steel seizure happened then it
stopped dead and since then it has gone
back and completely revised its proposed
law in these interesting respects
originally they were to be extended a
year now it's eight months originally
they didn't do very much to the wage
stabilization board now as a result of
this experience they practically
re-write the law affecting the wage
stabilization board and take away from
it all the powers it claimed in this
particular decision so they would still
have a wage stabilization board that
would be fixing wages while there would
be a price control of fixing prices and
neither of them would pay much attention
to what the other was doing this seems
to be the situation present would that
be continued under fire Leslie I would
imagine so but the new board will be
limited entirely to the question of cut
wages are within the stabilization
formula have nothing to do with
union-shop or fringe benefits and its it
membership will be made up of public
members only and those would have to be
confirmed by the Senate so we have our
hands on the weights table Cemetery I
believe you come from the very
interesting state of Utah your governor
governor Lee has attracted a great deal
of attention and you have a senator
that's up for reelection this year so
I'm sure that our audience would like a
few expressions from you on the
political scene in the mountain states
now has the Utah delegation to the
Republican National Convention been
selected that was selected on me I can't
remember the day but it was selected a
couple of weeks ago in Salt Lake and it
is 100% for Senator Taft 14 delegates
and and what's the situation generally
in the mountain states in the Republican
Party well a Senator Taft will have the
great majority of the delegates from the
mountains
there have been one or two places where
an Eisenhower delegator - has slipped in
but overwhelmingly it's overwhelmingly
tax country and are you personally
supporting senator taft i have announced
my position that way and I'm happy that
my state supported me and since that you
have since the governor governor Lee is
up for re-election and also senator
Watkins in your state but you care to
predict for our audience how you toe is
likely to go in 1952 well my sense of
the attitude in Utah is that there as
everywhere else there's a great unrest a
great feeling that this is time for a
change and I'm sure it's going to sweep
both senator Watkins and governor Lee
back into office together with many
other Republican nominees what do you
think the effect is going to be on the
election of mr. Truman stand on seizure
hasn't he in effect carried his party
pretty far over to the left with the
statements by vice president Barkley and
Secretary Tobin and so on what's going
to be the effect on the nomination well
I think he's made it very difficult for
the middle-of-the-road Democrats or The
Jeffersons Jeffersonian Democrats to
stay with the Democratic Party
not only with him as an individual but
with the party whose past he says he's
going to man you think that it's likely
then that the Democratic Party this year
will have a new deal nominee and that
they will run on a
on the New Deal platform and the fair
deal platform that the president is
insisting applying I think there's every
every evidence that that will happen
the only possible candidates the consent
from that is Senator Russell and I doubt
that he's got power enough to get the
nomination you don't think that it's
likely that we'll have a candidate
that's nominated by both parties then I
certainly am not in favor of the
one-party system and I hope the
Republicans don't contribute to it and
and and you also think that that it
would be best for the country if there
is a real debate and a race between a
new dealer a fair dealer and a
conservative Republican I think the
American people have been wanting that
for twenty years and I hope we have the
wisdom to give it to him this time and
as a final question sir since you come
from the great Mormon state of Utah and
the Mormons have been known to be
conservative in the past is the state
leaning toward conservatism now do you
think well my election would indicate a
movement in that direction and I think
the 1952 elections will bear it out
I see so well thank you very much for
being with us tonight the editorial
board for this edition of the launching
chroma scope was mr. William Bradford
Huie and mr. Henry Hazlitt our
distinguished guests was the honorable
Wallace F Bennett United States Senator
from Utah
it seems like a nice idea on the wedding
day the bride and groom give watches to
each other if you're planning a wedding
you may be glad to know that recognizing
the social acceptance of this custom
lawn gene has produced an exciting
series of duets exquisite lawn gene
watches in matching styles each bride's
watch a diminutive replica of the
groom's watch exchanging watches is
likewise a growing custom between
husbands and wives for anniversary gifts
and for any gift vacation no other name
on a watch means so much as launching
the world's most honored watch the only
watch in history to win 10 world's fair
grand prizes twenty eight gold medals
and so many honors for accuracy from the
world's observatories and yet you may
buy and own or buy and proudly give the
launching watch for as little as seventy
one fifty C launching duets
another beautiful launching watches sold
only by authorized jeweler agencies lawn
jean the world's most honored watch
premiere product of the lawn Jean with
no much company since eighteen sixty six
maker of watches of the highest
character
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at this
same time for the long gene Khurana
scope a television journal of the
important issues of the hour broadcast
on behalf of launching the world's most
honored watch and with noir
distinguished companion to the world
honored launching this is frank night
reminding you that long Jean and
Whitmore watches are sold and serviced
from coast to coast by more than four
thousand leading jewelers who proudly
display this emblem agency for launching
with noir watches
it's time for the lawn team Chronicle a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which noir
watts company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching horoscope mr. William Bradford
Huie
editor of the american mercury and mr.
James H R Cromwell former United States
minister to Canada our distinguished
guests for this evening is the honorable
William F Fenton United States senator
from Connecticut the opinions expressed
are necessarily those of the speaker
senator Benin it's a pleasure to have
you with us tonight sir on the krona
scope I can you for our for our viewers
will you identify yourself politically
are you a new dealer a supporter of the
president sir in general I have a very
consistent supporter of the president
though I differ with him and his
advisors in certain major ways I with
Senator Paul Douglas fight to deal
harder the most administration men do to
get our budget into balance to cut back
on expenditures I have fought subsidies
to agriculture beet sugar subsidies and
other subsidies but roughly speaking and
certainly on the foreign policy I would
describe myself as a supporter of the
president your sort of sound money new
dealer then is that correct I like to
think of myself that way there are those
who woke who won't use that definition
applied to me you believe in having a
balanced budget in other words senator
is that right Paul Douglas and I have
joined together in recommending not only
a cut the senton and a half billion
dollars out of the budget
mr. Cromwell but in trying to close up a
tax loopholes maybe to catch some rich
fellows like the Cromwell's to pick up
another two and a half billion dollars
to bring the cash or budget into balance
and about ten billion dollars would do
it I'm sure
viewers would like a prediction from you
sir as to whether you think the budget
is likely to be balanced this year mr.
Hui there's not a chance in the world
it's going to be out of balance by
opinions in a presidential election year
you'll never get the Congress to pass
the tax bill which the president
recommended which I would be for and
you're never going to get the Congress
to make these cuts in appropriations
bills because the pressures of too many
people are involved to spend the money
you remember that cynical advice don't
you of old Uncle Joe cannon to a young
congressman my son never vote a for a
tax bill or against an appropriation
bill that applies that particularly
applies to put in an election year I say
sir now sir I believe that you have
taken a rather strong position on the
Civil Rights program and our viewers are
very much interested in that tonight
because General Eisenhower this week
took a very firm stand against a federal
civil rights program yes now what what
is your position on civil rights sir
well I'm a great admirer of General
Eisenhower and I have respect for his
judgment but I differ with him and I
differ with him sharply on this
particular question civil rights mr. hua
is a problem for all the people not a
problem state-by-state and the reason
it's a problem for all the people is
that our failure in the field of civil
rights in our failure in the field of
our racial relations are doing justice
to our knee group Negro group and other
racial minorities is picked up by the
Communists all over the world and thrown
back at us and indeed it's the most
damaging of all the communist propaganda
we forget the two thirds of the peoples
of the world have colored skins and day
after day the communist propaganda
hammers into the minds of these people
that we discriminate
we're in just we don't live up to our
democratic preachments and that's too
important to let Mississippi and Alabama
decide that's a problem for all the
American people but do you think SN
that it's possible to do away with these
personal feelings by legislation not a
bit of it it's a long slow educational
process mr. Cromwell but as with all
education you throw your hat in front of
you we have a full civil rights
legislation up in the state of
Connecticut it doesn't mean that there
isn't stomp a discrimination week we had
can't get rid of it merely by passing
laws but when the people of the state
say together we stand against this it's
against the policy of the state we are
going to set up courts and commissions
we have a case in the state right now
against the labor union for refusing to
permit Negroes to join and it's the
first case of its kind in the country
and it's a fine thing for the people of
our state to get the education that's
involved in that case well now let's see
the dues that American people now have
before them on this General Eisenhower I
believe has taken a rather firm stand
against federal action in the civil
rights matter that's the way I read his
his stay there no there are no
qualifying clauses he's he's simply
against it senator Taft has certain
qualifying clauses senator Kefauver
who's been on this program now you I
believe sir are almost completely on the
other side from from General Eisenhower
you believe in federal action I'm not
trying to win any southern delegates I'm
not a candidate for the presidency but
out of my long experience in foreign
policy mr. Cooley I represented the
United States at eight international
conferences as a delegate of this
country I've talked to the people of
other countries who sent delegates there
and this is thrown at us all the time
and not only by the Russians but
naturally by the Indians by others I
told on the floor of the Senate last
month in fighting the McCarran
immigration bill the study of mrs. the
story of mrs. Benton and me being in
Japan in 1937 we saw the black flags
break out all over Japan it was the
anniversary of our exclusion act when we
said to the crowd
sensitive people of Japan not one of you
is fit to come into the United States
Japan went in the morning all historians
agree that our exclusion act against the
Japanese can be one of the major factors
that led to the attack on Pearl Harbor
so I give that as a quick illustration
to show how important action in this
field is from the standpoint of all our
people so if you are a member of the
Senate next year you head on yes when
you remember why your constituents can
depend on you to try to overcome the
traditional southern opposition to to
federal legislation in this field mr.
Hui connecticut's a pretty literate
state that they didn't know that I agree
with you I wouldn't have a chance to go
back to the Senate senator we'd like a
few words from you sir on this on your
activities in the mutual security
program the money that we are sending to
Europe now I believe that you have been
responsible for an amendment to that
program not just what are you trying to
do with that amendment sir well I'm
trying to combat communism in Europe and
to strengthen the hands of our
administrative officers who are fighting
communism of course the basic purpose of
the mutual Security Act is to fight
communism and to prepare ourselves to
fight communism if we come to an open a
outbreak of hostility and specifically
how will your how will your program help
in combating communism in Europe
well my Benton Amendment tells mr.
Harriman and his associates the
administrators of this act to spend
these vast sums of money to six million
four hundred million now under
discussion in such ways as to discourage
the great European monopolies and
cartels which hold back production and
hamstring productivity which is the very
thing we're trying to encourage and in
the second place to discourage the
Communist labor unions and to encourage
the development of the kind of free
labor unions really fighting for the
welfare of the workers of the kind we
have here in the United States Senator I
think that great many people don't
realize the difference between the way
businesses can
ducted here in the United States you're
absolutely right and the way it's
conducted in Europe I wonder if you
would give us a little discussion about
the difference between competitive
business in the United States and
monopoly business or cartel business as
they tournament in Europe well you put
your finger mr. Cromwell right on the
basic difference the basic difference in
attitudes of the American people goes
right back to 1890 when we passed the
Sherman Antitrust Act
there isn't any antitrust legislation in
Europe at all our laws a mr. Geoffrey
Crowther of the London economist put the
thing wonderfully when he once said we
put a man into the House of Lords in
England for the very thing in the United
States for which you put him in a
singsing Penitentiary our laws say you
can't combine and merge and monopolize
fixed markets fixed prices control
production fail to put in new machinery
and and eliminate competition all over
Europe the European businessman is
trained to exactly the opposite
viewpoint and every European country is
run in a business sense by the the
cartels and the monopolies what do you
think the chances are of changing the
European point of view on that of
changing the European business man's
busy this is an entrenched viewpoint
that makes the gap between the European
and the business communities
psychologically in American business
communities much greater than the
Atlantic Ocean it will take years
oddly enough the best chance right now I
thinks in Germany senator then you can
break it up in Germany there's hope for
breaking it up throughout my face very
interesting our audience of course
understands
are up for reelection in Connecticut and
quite frankly I believe the Republicans
think that they have a chance to win
your seat this year it is rumored now
what is pretty you expect a very
vigorous campaign I assume in
Connecticut it's sure to be a vigorous
campaign that Mister hurry because the
state is small and compact highly
literate politically and there will be a
much money spent in Connecticut by the
Republicans in the expectation that I
may be one of the vulnerable senators
who can't be successfully dislodged I
don't like to tell them now they'd
better save their party but perhaps
you'll assure that was that for me now
and and what position sir
do you take nationally in the night in
the race between the Democrats and the
Republicans have you endorsed any any
any candidate for the presidency a we
and Connecticut have endorsed my senior
colleague Brian McMahon I believe that
the Democrats have too much sense to
nominate a candidate with whom we can't
win you know I live there for predicted
Democratic victory though I agree with
you there are some Democratic candidates
now in the field with whom we can't win
a senator so there is a tie-up between
the candidate and the anticipated
victory of that I'm the first to admit
I'm sure that our viewers very much
appreciate your views tonight sir and
thank you for being with us I
congratulate you on the quality of this
program mr. Lee the editorial board for
this edition of the launching
Crona scope was mr. William Bradford
Huie
and mr. James HR Cromwell our
distinguished guest was the Honorable
William F Fenton the United States
Senator from Connecticut
you know the problem confronting the
manufacturer of an article of extreme
precision such as a long gene is to
deliver it to its eventual owner in the
same perfect condition in which it
leaves the pathway now for that reason
long gene watches have always been
distributed directly from the factory
through a limited number of jewelers
qualified by knowledge and experience to
handle watches of non gene quality these
jewelers are authorized lon jean wit nor
jeweller 8 and in this way you're
assured that the long gene watts which
you buy is a worthy representative of
the only watch in history to win 10
world's fair grand prizes twenty eight
gold medals and highest honors for
accuracy from the leading government
observatories of the world so when next
you buy a watch for yourself or for an
important gifts occasion
see long Jean the world's most honored
watch sold under our factory guarantee
only authorized lawn gene with nor
jeweler agency throughout the world no
other name on a watch means so much as
launching the world's most honored watch
premier products of the long gene with
Norma's company since eighteen sixty six
maker of watches of the highest
character
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time for the launching promise co a
television journal of the important
issues of the our broadcast on behalf of
launching the world's most honored watch
and wit nor distinguished companion for
the world honored lawn jean this is
frank night reminding you that lawn jean
and wit nor watches are sold and
serviced from coast to coast by more
than four thousand leading jewelers who
proudly display this emblem agency for
lawn jean wit nor what
it's time for the launching funnest Oh a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which
snore what's company maker of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
David Ross tonight the lawn gene Cronus
cope turns away from the man-made
problems of the world to an examination
of spiritual values a subject in keeping
with the holiday season to help you find
the truth father John Sheeran CSP editor
of Catholic world Reverend dr. William
rosenbloom rabbi of Temple Israel of the
city of New York Reverend dr. Robert J
McCracken pastor of Riverside Church a
father Charles Howard graph of st.
John's Church in the village our
moderator is mr. William Bradford Huie
a Khurana scope viewers have now
satisfied all of the material
requirements for Christmas and tonight
we'd like to explore some of their
spiritual yearnings and now father graft
if our average viewer tonight could ask
for a spiritual gift for Christmas what
gifts do you think would be highest on
the list I think that men with gue are
looking for security a security which is
based not upon material factors but the
security which is based upon God the
Creator was the ultimate security for
all men I think men want peace a a peace
that can only be found and as it is
exemplified in this season and the
Christ child in the manger a piece of
the Christ that reconcile and thirdly I
think men are looking for a moral
fortitude and stamina in a time when
not recognizing always moral values so
security peace and moral stamina
now rabbi rosenbloom has been said that
this is a nervous age and aspirant age
the age of tension now sir what could
you offer to our viewers as some relief
from these tensions of our time well
that's not what I offer but I think as I
analyze the age while it is true it's an
age of afar take an headache there great
many tensions in all areas and the
phrase ask for an age is very shall I
say eloquent description on the negative
side I believe there's a positive
awareness about these tensions that
people generally want to do something
about it
it's an aspiring age aspiring with
reference to ideals and I think our
presence here tonight exemplifies what
the formula would be for to improve
conditions because the religions of the
world we represent some of them having
they're keeping the spiritual ideals the
moral values that will make for peace
and make for a better world and I think
if we can get together in a more
constructive program I believe that's
one of the great hopes of the future
father Sheeran the infant Christ has
been called a symbol of weakness and now
in these days of least to meet the
challenges of our time do you think that
we need a symbol of power well show that
the infant Christ is a symbol of human
weakness about the same time I believe
that he is a symbol of divine power not
only divine physical power I firmly
believe that as God he created the Sun
and the moon stars and as Francis
Townsend says that he swings the world
like a trinket at his wrists but more
importantly he is a possessor of
infinite moral power and I do firmly
believe that his edicts as lawgiver must
be obeyed and any ruler who chooses to
violate
the natural law established by God must
go down to destruction
what is the Christ contributed to the
concept of human dignity well I'd say
that he constantly emphasized the
dignity of the human person and his
teachings he consorted with the
offscouring you might say the scum of
the streets of Jerusalem about two at
the same time he showed a reference for
the souls of those persons and I think
that that dignity as founders in his
teaching has come down to us and has
been incorporated in the Magna Carta and
the Bill of Rights but more importantly
I'd say that the effect of the
Incarnation has given Western thinking a
awareness of the dignity of man the fact
that God chose to incarnate himself and
human nature he became one of us in
order that we might be adopted into the
family of God and I think that the fact
of the Incarnation the fact of the birth
of God and Christmas has given to all
Western thinking a very clear awareness
of the dignity of the human person and
this Christmas does the Christmas 1952
who ground for hope to the future well I
think it does hold hope provided we have
humility not so long ago someone said
that arrogance is the chief evil of our
time that's very true and I think is
necessary for us to kneel down humbly in
adoration of the infant in the crib dr.
McCracken most of us are familiar with
professor to join this figure of the
human procession creeping up the
mountainside rather laborious Lee and
their periods in human history when the
procession seems to make progress and
other periods when it seems to be in
confusion and retreat now how do you
feel sir on Christmas 1952 do you think
that we are there our procession at this
time is making progress or that perhaps
we are so confused we may be in retreat
I know mr. Huey how I would like to feel
I would like to think that we were
making distinct progress
I am disposed to avoid generalizations
because while Toynbee certainly made one
I had a professor of history who used to
say to us never generalize in saying it
making a generalization at the same time
I think it's incontestable but that
things are going from bad to worse in
the world I am reminded of what the late
Vikon Gray said in 1914 when war broke
out lights are going out all over Europe
yet I on Christmas Eve 1952 I'm not
without hope because after all
Christianity is an optimistic religion
founded on a provisionally pessimistic
view of man it's when man realizes his
predicament that he he feels need and
it's at that point of course that
Christmas is particularly significant in
as much as it means that man isn't left
to work out his own salvation well now
are the faiths represented here the
principle judeo-christian faith is it
true that today they all are alerted to
the great danger of our time the danger
of the all-powerful state the danger of
communism are they do they all recognize
the principle danger of our time I would
say that there's a deepening
understanding on the on the part of the
Western face of the problem presented to
us by Soviet Communism though I would
there want to add that we're deeply
conscious too of problems closer to home
and of the danger always of decadence
from within a point I might add that 20
brings out yes father graph do you feel
hopeful as an individual for the human
procession in 1952 I do very much
because I think that the realization
that faith is ultimately the basis of
just seeking for security and peace and
moral stamina that reawakening is going
to have a profound effect upon all of us
I am very hopeful for the years which
lie ahead because I think men are
realizing now there is an awakening of
leadership for us to have hopes for free
government rabbi Rosenbloom is it
necessary for us to have must men Heil
faith and all in order to support free
government I think without faith we have
seen that there is no free government
because every single dictator that we've
had in the past those in recent years
and those are in power now one of the
first things they tried to do by force
and degree just to take faith out of the
lives of people and I think you find it
in the democratic countries like our own
while there are some tensions and
difficulties and disappointments and we
are in a great situation so there's
always this welling up of faith faith in
God their faith that life has an
ulterior purpose and I think faith and
freedom go together father sure and you
mentioned the great documents Magna
Carta and Declaration is a noble works
that have sprung from the mind of man do
you think that those could have sprung
only from men who had faith over
definitely but a very firm definite to
precise religious principles and is it
true today when the threat of
totalitarianism is over all of us is it
true that all totalitarian governments
of themselves must first destroy faith
or attempt to destroy faith dr.
McCracken is that - well I I don't know
that they destroy faith actually there's
all the states in the leader the leader
principle I think
faith in God seems to go whether you're
thinking of Hitler or whether you're
thinking of Soviet well the the
totalitarian concept if you're going to
believe in the all-powerful state wasn't
that what Rome period of Christianity
for instance the idea that the
individual man considered himself
important godlike worthy to be free on
and in the the outlook for 1953 do all
of you believe that that there is a a
realization on the part of the American
people of a need for more faith or
proper balance between faith and reason
I think they're showing it was that you
win in all our synagogues and churches
and their way of life a returnee so to
the ideas of faith and do you think that
perhaps more more Americans will go to
church for instance in the next 24 hours
and did last year well certainly there's
a heightening of the religious element
in the Christmas celebrations this year
I've noticed that well gentlemen I'm
sure that I viewers have appreciated
these expressions from you and thank you
very much for being with us they
distinguished guests on the lawn
Giancana scope this evening were father
John Sheeran CSP editor of the Catholic
world Reverend dr. William rosenbloom
rabbi of Temple Israel of the city of
New York Reverend dr. Robert J McCracken
pastor of Riverside Church father
Charles Howard Graf of st. John's Church
in the village they moderator for this
special holiday program was mr. William
Bradford Huie the problem of selecting a
gift of great prestige for someone near
and dear to you is most happily solved
with a lawn gene watch throughout the
world no other name on a Watts carries
as much prestige as long gene the
world's most honored watch 10 world's
fair grand prizes and twenty eight gold
medals for excellence and elegance and
highest honors for accuracy from the
leading government observatories have
made long gene in fact the world
on a watch now whenever you need to
present a gift of great prestige for a
birthday for an anniversary for an
important occasion
remember these facts and remember too
that you may buy an own or buy and
proudly give a long Jean watch for as
little as seventy one fifty long gene
the world's most honored watch premier
product of the long gene with North US
company since eighteen sixty six maker
of watches of the highest character we
invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at this
same time for the long gene college
group the television journal of the
important issues of they are broadcast
on behalf of launching the world's most
honored watch and with noir
distinguished companion to the world
honored long gene this is frank night
reminding you that long gene and which
noir watches are sold and service from
coast to coast by more than four
thousand leading jewelers who proudly
display this emblem agency for long gene
which nor one
it's time for the long gene kana scope a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Fridays a
presentation of the laun gene but nor
watch company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching chrome scope
Larry litter from the CBS television
news staff and august texture chief
editorial writer for The New York Herald
Tribune our distinguished guest for this
evening is Sir Alexander Grantham
governor-general of Hong Kong most of us
have become familiar with the name Hong
Kong if not with that British crown
colony itself because of the Korean War
and those charges that the island of
Hong Kong was furnishing Communist China
with the seniors of war while British
and American troops were fighting the
Chinese Communists on the other side in
Korea but our guest tonight who is
governor of that strategic Ted Leiden
knows the story so Alexander how much
illegal trade was going on with the
Chinese Communists while British and
American troops were actually fighting
the Communists in Korea well the best
way of answering that would be to quote
a former American Consul General in Hong
Kong who said a miracle to give
substantiation to then I'll make these
points Hong Kong has loyally carried out
the terms of the United Nations embargo
on trade and strategic or semi strategic
Goods with China
moreover Hong Kong itself produces
nothing nothing whatever that Communist
China wants therefore all the Communist
China wants from Hong Kong has to come
from other countries first and other
countries will not export to Hong Kong
unless they are satisfied that those
Goods of strategic value are not going
to be passed on to communist China if
those countries want to export to
communist China the goods will bypass
Hong Kong delivery
right Hong Kong because they are afraid
of the controls and the penalties that
Hong Kong imposes on such form of
illegal trade sir exactly isn't there a
large mass of legal trade going on now
between Hong Kong and China or has that
been greatly reduced as a result of
these circumstances the answer to that
is yes in both cases that might seem a
little bit illogical but Hong Kong has
as its natural trading partner China but
as a result of the United Nations
embargo and also are the terms and
conditions of the Chinese Communists
imposed on trade of that with their
country the trade has dropped very
considerably our trade now has since the
imposition of the embargo has dropped by
one-third which naturally has had a very
serious effect on the economy of the
colony and the livelihood of its people
there what would happen to Sir Alexander
if Hong Kong cut off all is trade with
China because China is not a
peace-loving country and is even now
threatening Formosa now if I might kick
the ball back at you mr. Sherr might I
ask you the effect on Hong Kong or on
calvinist china effect on Hong Kong now
the effect on Hong Kong would be very
serious indeed because Hong Kong is not
self-supporting foodstuffs forests in
the food staff sir roughly taking the
overall picture we get about half our
food from Communist China notably pigs
and notably fresh vegetables and then
Hong Kong would have to be supplied from
overseas and since the distances are
very great either from Britain or from
Australia or America it would be quite a
problem though sir alexander in other
words if at any time the chinese
communists wish to get hong kong they
could merely starve you out there
oh no if it if it came to that and that
is really war and when it's war then we
would be a fortress and since the free
world controls the seas it would be
possible and
and quite sure would be done to continue
to supply Hong Kong with all the
foodstuffs that it needed to carry on
the fight for freedom Hong Kong was
overcome by the Japanese early in the
Second World War
isn't that then that is quite correct
Hong Kong was attacked on Pearl Harbor
day and it surrendered to the
overwhelming forces of the Japanese on
Christmas Day but we have to remember
that at that time the Japanese had
control not only of the sea but also the
air whereas today we have controlled
both of the sea and of the air which
makes itself it is a thoroughly
defensible island I certainly do
I do not pose myself as a military
expert but I am quoting the opinion of
the highest military authorities in
Britain and without mentioning any names
also the United States sir Alexander how
valuable is Hong Kong to the free world
as a naval base is that does that
outweigh its economic importance as a
naval base I should say it's not very
great at the moment because from the
British point of view there is the far
bigger and more up-to-date naval base at
Singapore which is only 1500 miles to
1500 miles away that is not the real
importance of Hong Kong today well sir
Alexander is a Hong Kong ever threatened
by the Chinese Communists do they ever
make gestures dangerous gestures in your
direction and well I've got to use
polite language mr. Ascher but they make
sometimes impolite noises at us but it
hasn't got further than that they don't
they don't make it a major part of their
propaganda to agitate continually the
Hong Kong no no that is eased off
considerably they did in the early days
they were accusing Hong Kong of all
sorts of crimes and iniquities amongst
those being a stooge of American
imperialism
well mr. Alexander what are your
relations with the Chinese an amine and
are they hostile or you conduct business
on a polite collect correct basis or is
there
actually a friendly feeling the official
relationship is nil we have no official
relationships whatever I would describe
the attitude of the Chinese Communists
towards Hong Kong as one of cold
hostility but mainly other passive
rather than of an active nature well
then did you approve of the visit of the
labor the former Labour Prime Minister
of Britain - vaping cemetery well now
you've handed me a real red hot potato
but I'm very fond of potatoes so I'll
even take this hotpot I thought that
visit was unfortunate shall we leave it
at that
well sir identify could change the
subject what is life like now inside the
island of Hong Kong there are I think a
great number of refugees who have come
in from China the economic conditions
depressed is living there tolerable I'll
take that question by stages backwards
living is certainly tolerable and there
is a remarkable degree of confidence we
are very overcrowded and I'm sure you'll
appreciate that when I tell you that on
the liberation of the colony by the
British Pacific Fleet in August 1945 the
population was half a million today it
is two and a half millions and our trade
has dropped by one-third and that the
way the people of Hong Kong carry on
under such difficult conditions I think
is really most remarkable mr. Alexander
I take it that most of the people in
Hong Kong are Chinese I'd like to ask
you are they friendly to the communist
regime or to the nationís regime in
Formosa originally when I say originally
that means 1949 when the Communists
overran the whole of China then they
were inclined to be friendly to the new
regime which was the communist regime
they didn't then see it in its true
but they are now disillusioned and that
was well demonstrated last October when
on the respective national days of the
Communists the first of October and of
the Nationalists on the 10th of October
the display of flags on the 10th of
October was tremendous greater than I've
ever seen it before
as chiang kai-shek ever come to Hong
Kong now he has not come to Hong Kong at
any time whatever well as Sir Alexander
I take it that nevertheless in this
flood of refugees that you had
originally there must have been some
Chinese communist agents some sort of a
Fifth Column now is there any danger
that Hong Kong might be entirely subvert
it by the Chinese Communists and you
might wake up one morning and find
yourself a prisoner there I should say
the danger of that is about nil
admittedly some agents do slip in but we
know who the main communist leaders are
in the colony and after a requisite
moment we would if we wanted to pick
them up but we prefer to keep them above
ground rather than have them underground
when the net result and a net of Hong
Kong is an asset to the free world as
well as to Great Britain itself very
definitely very definitely
well incidentally is there are the
communists in Red China talking about
increasing trade now now that there is a
settlement Geneva well they certainly
are yes oh that's one of the great
propaganda lines intelligent businessmen
won't fall for it although they would
like to see legitimate trade in non
embargo goods with China increasing what
is the value then of Hong Kong is it a
place to get information from behind a
so-called bamboo curtain oh yes we go I
just think it's it's it's the best of
all places for that what so Alexander
may I ask you this
could you say
in Hong Kong that you can read the
temperature of the world in regard to
war and peace in Asia and you get some
idea of how the Chinese feel about this
well my answer to that would be when I
but I would say the chances of war are
not very great but whether that's
wishful thinking or not I really
wouldn't like to say you mean other
words the chances of the 10 years making
further war against Hong Kong against
Hong Kong I should say at this juncture
No thank you very much it's been most
interesting to have you here tonight so
Alexandre oh it's been nice to know the
opinions expressed on the lawn Jane crow
no scope for those of the speakers the
editorial board for this edition of the
launching crow no scope was Larry looser
and Auguste texture our distinguished
guests were Sir Alexander Grantham
governor-general of Hong Kong the old
words accuracy and reliability take on a
new and a true meaning when applied to a
lone gene watch hello Jeanne wat Springs
priceless peace of mind for knows where
one stands with time all the time for
almost a century lon gene has made
watches which by Observatory
measurements have consistently been
equal or superior in accuracy to the
highest achievements of each decade
further proof is found in this fact
among the finest watches of the world
only launching watches have been
honoured with ten world's fair grand
prizes and twenty eight gold medals yet
though lone jean is one of the finest of
all watches there are many beautiful
models for both ladies and gentlemen for
as little as seventy one fifty whatever
the type whatever the style laun jean
has made it for you so when next you buy
a watch either for yourself or is an
important gift these are facts to
remember for truly the satisfaction that
comes from owning a lawn jean is above
and beyond price launching the world's
most honored watch the world's most
honored gift premiere product of the
laun Jean but Noah Watts company since
eighteen sixty six maker of watches of
the high
character
this is frank night reminding you that
long gene and Whitner watches are sold
and service from coast to coast by more
than four thousand leading jewelers who
proudly display this emblem agency for
lawn gene with nor watches at lawn gmat
nor jewelers see Atmos the perpetual
motion clock created by lock ultra Epis
runs without winding without electricity
powered only by variations in the
temperature of the atmosphere
atmospheric of like ultra division of
launching with nor
it's time for the long gene Khurana
scope a television journal of the
important issues of the hour brought to
you every Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene wit nor
watch company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night glad to say hello again
after our summer vacation now may I
introduce our co-editors for this
edition of the launching chroma scope
Edward P Morgan and Larry looser both
from the CBS television news staff our
distinguished guest for this evening is
Sir gladwyn Jeb permanent representative
of the United Kingdom's delegation to
the United Nations
it's a gladwyn we're glad to welcome you
back to Corona scope particularly at a
time when the United Nations General
Assembly is moving into the area of
decisions on Korea it's of course no
news to you sir that nevertheless many
Americans have become what we might call
disenchanted with the whole Korean
business and at the outset of this
special assembly session are greeted
with headlines of differences among the
houses of cousins between us the British
and the Americans can you straighten us
out a little bit on that sir before we
get into the main discussion well all
this question difference is it may be
legitimate to discuss them but I like to
say just as the outset that we've got to
agree after what is the position you are
the most powerful individual nation in
the earth but we we as a great power and
we are furthermore I would remind you at
the center of a Commonwealth which
comprises well over I think a quarter of
the population of the globe and
therefore if we agree we're safe there
whole free world in my view is safe and
and for that reason we must agree
there's there's no alternative we've got
to agree but again if we are to agree
it's no good just
calling ourselves each other names it's
no good you're just announcing us as a
pieces it's no good I'll just announcing
you as imperialists or whatever is said
by some people in Great Britain that
doesn't help at all the thing is that we
are or we certainly want to be partners
what does that mean that means that as
democracies both of us we have and we're
bound to express the majority opinion in
our countries and quite right - and why
shouldn't we and if we do have I express
the majority opinion in our governments
it's no no point in thinking that it's
the end of the world or anything
terrible happening we've got to get
agreement as a result of the expression
this expression of opinion and therefore
at some times obviously a one government
has got to defer to the views of the
other government otherwise there is no
partnership now in the Far East of
course we wouldn't dispute that you
after your enormous sacrifices in Korea
have got shall we say a major interest
in the Far East but nevertheless I
suggest but we have also made sacrifices
in view of our other commitments quite
considerable we have a right to express
our point of view and we don't see why
our opinion should not at least be heard
so gladwyn to get down to specific
questions the United States strongly
opposes the participation of India a
British Commonwealth nation in this
Korean political conference that follows
the armistice sometime next fall or this
fall now could you would you care to
state what the United Kingdom's position
is on the participation of India in this
political conference on Korea yes I
would but that of course means that we
must explain in two words where our
general position is and we think that in
the first place the United Nations has
scored a great victory in repelling
aggression and pushing back the
aggressor way came from and it hadn't
been for that which is largely or your
initial decision and where should we now
in a terrible situation with a third
world war threatenings let me see under
plumb attic and interrupted diplomats
are glad when that brings up a point
right there that it seems to me is quite
important to Americans and that is that
we have been taught in school
and just in our general life that when
you go into a game or into a war you're
supposed to win it a lot of people think
that there has been no victory in Korea
that we haven't won it but that seems to
be bothering I don't agree I think we
have won it and so far as the game is
being played with one we've repelled
aggression and what is are having
repelled aggression what are our
objectives now I think with our
objectives yours and ours our objectives
are the same and I'm sure that's been
said on both sides of what is the
objective the objective is the
unification by peaceful means of career
and that is our objective well if you
rule out war because we're not going to
go on with this war having won off what
we set out to do what is the procedure
if you're going to unify Korea by
peaceful means you're going to do it by
peaceful means the most peaceful means
mean it means by talking by negotiation
what else can it mean as if you're going
to have negotiation you must do it in
the best possible way that is the same
us get into the negotiation anybody who
can affect one way or another but affect
definitely the situation in Korea and
have an effect on the peaceful
unification of Korea and that is why we
support the Indians and indeed the
Russians the Goodwin is also a question
who does the negotiation I suppose the
United States for example is strongly
opposed to the invitation to a Soviet
Russia to participate in this political
conference on Korea as a member of the
United Nations side how do you feel
about that well we don't Tim we think
under the strict interpretation of
article 60 it's true there are two sides
there are those who've thought on both
sides on one side the the Koreans and
the North Koreans and the Communist
Chinese and the other the 16 Nations and
the strict interpretation you might say
there's the two sides that maybe say we
wouldn't dispute that but if you want to
have a successful negotiation to the
peaceful unification of career they
argue you have to get in some other
people do and we think the General
Assembly has a perfect right to
recommend and to recommend because it
recommends must be accepted by you and
by the Chinese that a visa can recommend
that other states who have a great
interest in Korea should with that
express their point of view that's what
we think but you don't think that Russia
should be exposed as
a apart from her fictitious role as a
neutral in Korea bearing no
responsibility and to actually sit on
the aggressor side of this political
conference I didn't say she was a
neutral in Korea I think she hasn't been
altogether neutral and gets another
point but I think that her presence is
necessary if you want to get as a
solution by peaceful means it's all I
said well sir gladwyn would you say sir
that one of the things that might be
bothering Americans at this point
particularly is that they are afraid
that a what might be called a roundtable
negotiation would be one of appeasement
at the end it out of discussion they
might lose something no I don't think so
at all what is appeasement appeasement I
suppose is doing something dishonorable
in order to secure a solution something
that you wouldn't agree to on model or
other grounds that would be appeasement
but if you went into negotiation you're
not compelled to accept anything
dishonourable and you and we and either
nades nor fools
neither of us will agree to anything
dishonourable but something's that but
no reason why we shouldn't enter into a
negotiation that's quite another thing
negotiation is not appeasement well when
you get projecting beyond this immediate
United Nations assembly meeting and into
the political conference that as Larry
said come sometime this fall what are
the mechanics sir as you see it is there
going to be an agreement a majority
agreement on a peace document or will it
be a matter of an axis between Britain
the United States and the Western Allies
on one side and China and Russia on the
other well if you ever get into
negotiation I hope we shall it isn't a
question of anybody imposing their will
in the resolution which we shall shortly
discuss in the United Nations is laid
down that there shouldn't be any
question of a majority view prevailing
and how can a majority view prevail if a
solution is not acceptable to you or
indeed to the other side it can't be
imposed and therefore it's laid down
that every country participating in the
in the negotiations there shall not be
bound except by any decision except by
don't consent and that applies to you
but is just one have to make the dubious
inference from that sir that there is
a great possibility that there won't be
an agreement and we'll just rock along
and with a divided Korea as we have with
a divided Germany yes it's quite
possible for the no he's my shouldn't
try for a better solution who knows what
may happen if you try so glad when you
think that the Korean peace conference
to take place this fall should be
strictly limited to the question of the
unification of Korea or should go into
other questions of the Far East well I
think certainly to start off with the
question of Korea
that's what laid down in the armistice
agreement that's perfectly right and
proper now if there is any progress on
that and if tanks a big if as soon as
possible if there should be any
disposition to discuss other questions
in the Far East well that could be done
either in the context of this particular
negotiation or in some other it is
possible
I wouldn't exclude that I think
certainly they ought to concentrate on
Korea first to try and get agreement on
career first I quite agree with that and
then if they if they find any agreement
on other questions you think possibly go
into them well why not well so glad when
I do ask you a question about Red China
Her Majesty's Government recognises Red
China and is my understanding that your
government would also like to see Red
China admitted into the United Nations
well we'd recognize Red China because we
think Red China is the government of
China and you mean the Communists a
government in Peking we think it is the
government of China and unfortunately or
fortunately a person there I don't go
into the model question at all herself
we never have we think that the it is
actually people who are governing China
now that's always say nothing else okay
we may ask you a question if Red China
were admitted to the United Nations who
then think that they would then
recognize Britain I don't know whether
it was there whether they they were
there was a change in Chinese
representation in the United Nations
would depend on a vote in the United
Nations whether that will happen I don't
know it will depend have some extent on
on how do the Chinese behave in these
negotiations and other things that
brings us quickly sir gladwyn to a final
question
most of our experts agree that the
overriding communist strategy is one to
try to divide the Allies what's the
British reading on
that effort as of now well I think that
the Soviet strategies undoubtedly to
divide their lives and to try and make
NATO a failure and divide us from you
that's their principal objective but
whether they're there they're present in
this conference or not is another
question it's quite arguable I only say
it's quite arguable this they were not
present in this negotiation they would
divide you and ask for more successful
if they were thank you very much sir
glad one for being with us on Rana stole
the opinions that you've heard our
speakers express tonight have been
entirely their own the editorial board
for this edition of the launching Cronus
Cove was Edward P Morgan and Larry
looser both of the CBS TV news staff our
distinguished guest was so glad when JEB
permanent representative of the United
Kingdom's delegation to the United
Nations now if you're contemplating the
purchase of a very fine watch it would
be profitable to compare the facts about
launching watches with the facts you
have about any other watch you will find
that the facts about lone gene are
convincing proof of surpassing quality
actual evidence that in the launching
watch you have one of the finest
timepieces in made in all the world for
in competition with the world's best
watches launching watches alone have one
for excellence and elegance ten world's
fair grand prizes and twenty eight gold
medals for accuracy highest honors from
the leading government observatories for
dependability a position of leadership
in sports in aviation and in science yet
though no gene is one of the very finest
watches made anywhere in all the world
alone gene watch is not excessively
expensive because you may buy and own or
buy and proudly give a long gene watch
for as little as seventy one fifty and
this is important whatever the price
every long gene watch is manufactured to
the highest
quality which have made launching the
world's most honored watch the world's
most honored gift launching premiere
product of the laun jean with nor what's
company since eighteen sixty six maker
of watches of the highest character
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time for the long gene Kranz code a
television journal of the important
issues of they are broadcast on behalf
of launching the world's most honored
watch and wit nor distinguished
companion watch to the world honoured
launching this is frank night reminding
you that launching and Whitner watches
are sold in service from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading
jewelers who proudly display this emblem
agency for long jean with nor watches